we're gonna get five random suggestions
from different sections of the room and
we're gonna drop B do a freestyle rap if
you are set in this section here what
would you like a rap about
you say magic Surfer
sorcerer thank you very much again I
think my option was even more exciting
but no a magic Sorcerer And thank you
for clarifying a magic sorcerer I'm
excited to hear what a normal sorcerer
would be
he was sorcerer a magic one all right
mate calm down foreign
brothels thank you very much sir yes
that did need clarification as well
because when when I hear brothel I don't
automatically go it's a Greek one isn't
it
ancient Greek oh that's someone who
realized they didn't want to be called
that was racist and they were like and
it's in the past it's fine it's true in
it you know oh oh I'm a prostitute oh
cool but he's like oh I'm a prostitute
in ancient times oh I bring some weight
to it some gravitas so the uh the magic
sorcerer and an ancient Greek brothel
it's this side of the room so far these
are quite good suggestions right have
high hopes for how this will continue
middle of the room what would you like
wrap them
this is you your suggestion was just
repudiated by someone at your table you
the New York Jets know
[Laughter]
it's the way of the crowd I don't like
it
I mean we can come to this you guys can
steal their suggestion what do you want
to rap about
being trapped in an open house that's
out of your price range incredible wow
look at it yeah look at all you people
here they're all home hunters being
cracking open house out of your crash
around this section what do you want to
rap about
a Nigerian lawyer who loves air fryers
are you a Nigerian lawyer who loves
airfryers you're not a lawyer are you
Nigerian amazing so you just you added
in your aspiration or or what what's
your job
you work in Fitness so it is Africa I
mean is it rude to say that lawyer ranks
above working in Fitness as a vocation
but it's accurate though isn't it so
I mean it depends look I mean look
lawyer is better than comedian and
lawyer is a very okay fine you [ __ ]
Auntie what do you want the system to
collapse
what if the lawyer is like a human
rights lawyer oh we like them now that's
not the lawyer I was picturing as a
[ __ ] yeah a prosecutor who was really
racist right
um a Nigerian lawyer who loves air
fryers thank you very much so you love
Air France because you work in Fitness
and they are the the most healthy way to
fry food the other option is to just not
fry food at all but
where is the Giant now a Nigerian lawyer
who loves air fryers it's a good
suggestion New York Jets no they didn't
want that being trapped from an open
house that you can't it's out of your
price range ancient Greek brothels so
good magic Sorcerers
um what sport are the New York Jets in
because I presume
[Applause]
football but not my kind of football
okay
okay where does the name Jets come from
what's the etymology of them I can tell
JFK LaGuardia there's some arguments
going on you're naming airports okay I
mean are they considered a good team or
a bad team a bad team everyone really
know is this a corporate outing for the
New York Jets
okay
well this is what we're going to do
we're gonna make him a rap about all
those things it's going to be very
enjoyable it's not me when you're as
atrociously embarrassingly bad as you're
expecting a privately educated middle
class white British boy to be so let's
do this
I want to lose weight want to avoid to
putting on calories Nigerian lawyer
comes up to me says Chris I'm no liar
like Nigerian princess use this fryer I
say hey I'll take care how does it fry
all of the food when it's just the air
he explains to me you gotta add a little
drop the oil starts to condense and gets
hot then it moves around the paddle goes
through Nigerian lawyer thank you you
countries like 400 million people gonna
grow larger it's gonna equal America and
surpass it someday bringing all the
airfryer Yum Yum to me I'm so excited
the best you can get basically the
opposite of the New York Jets why
I'm confused about it I'm shout it like
that [ __ ] without it no need for the
team not the best of all what should
they play not my kind of football that's
the one that you use with your toes this
is the one in your hand if you chose to
support the team and shout it at a
comedy show New York Jets some guy will
just say no we don't want that no need
for the rap I take it and fling it in
your face right back you sat there slap
jawed open mouth like a man trapped
there in an open house he starts to
worry says this is so strange I walked
him but clearly out of my price range I
thought it I saw it the rent is startled
I looked at the countertops they're all
marble I'm not partial to this type of
decoration we should have a fist fight
with the estate agent the person showing
me the realtor I'm like [ __ ] I've got
another one or three I need to leave but
there's no way to escape they look at me
I made the mistake of putting on my
finest shirt so they think I earn the
money they think that I'm a lawyer and
they look at me funny a prosecutor or
some type of human rights I see a Greek
girl yeah [ __ ] you tonight but not in
the present day she'll have me back in
history
ariadne might be her name that's a Greek
one people over there saying yeah he's
got it going on she goes down she's got
a subtle warm mouth and she's Greek so
of course big bushy eyebrows is that
offensive no it's in the past it's fine
for me to do it why because I asked I go
there I say I've got a lot to learn and
then they put it on some ancient Grecian
urn painting it in just the orange and
the black that's the type of pottery
they did way back my seeing periods
maybe minoan lasting I went and saw a
magic show and this guy stood on stage
I'm like yes y'all this guy's incredible
looks like Dumbledore a very long beard
are you sure there is Magic with this
man who's a sorcerer he says my life was
hard ever so tragic but then I rubbed a
lamp and gained the magic say this is
incredible I'd watch you for hours you
genuinely had the magic powers he says
yes the spirits in my vein I'm better
than Copperfield and David Blaine I say
You're really overselling it just a
little bit I'm magic I'm magic you're a
little [ __ ] whoa calm down what the [ __ ]
are you doing rabbit from the Hat all
the things you're pursuing then he does
some stuff that makes my knees go weak
like the lady that I met in the brothel
who's Greek
foreign